Trascrizione: Claudia Ciniglio
Revisore: Anaë François
(Voci in inglese in sottofondo)
(Fine delle voci in inglese in sottofondo)
(Musica e voci indistinte)
(Fine musica)
(Applausi)
"Non avrebbe potuto essere lavato mai più;
avrebbe dimostrato che l’uomo,
il genere umano, noi insomma,
eravamo potenzialmente capaci
di costruire una mole infinita di dolore;
e che il dolore è la sola forza
che si crei dal nulla,
senza spesa e senza fatica.
Basta non vedere, non ascoltare, non fare.
Se comprendere è impossibile,
conoscere è necessario.
Perché ciò che è accaduto può ritornare.
Le coscienze possono di nuovo essere
sedotte ed oscurate, anche le nostre".
Ho voluto iniziare con questo
passo di Primo Levi perché
oggi è la giornata mondiale del rifugiato.
Per spiegarvi come abbiamo creato il MOAS
dobbiamo ritornare all'8 luglio del 2013,
quando io e mio marito Christopher
ci trovavamo a Lampedusa.
Anzi, avevamo lasciato
il porto di Lampedusa
per andare in Tunisia, per lavoro.
Era una vacanza lavoro.
Eravamo in mare ed in questo tratto
Lapedusa-Tunisia abbiamo guardato
e tra le onde galleggiava una giacca.
Era un segno tangibile delle persone
che oggi muoiono in mare,
chiamati "i migranti".
Questi numeri, queste masse
che vengono spogliate dall'individualità.
E così è molto facile
trasformarli in fantasmi.
Noi non crediamo che queste
persone siano dei fantasmi.
E per questo, abbiamo voluto
metterci in gioco.
Papa Francesco, da Lampedusa,
ci lanciava un messaggio.
Un messaggio di solidarietà.
Vi leggo le sue frasi:
"Abbiamo perso il senso
della responsabilità.
La sofferenza degli altri quasi
non ci interessa più.
Non ci riguarda, non è affar nostro".
Però, in ogni senso, lui ci spronava
ad andare avanti, a metterci in gioco.
E quindi noi abbiamo voluto
abbattere il muro dell'indifferenza.
Ma come farlo? A parole?
No. Abbiamo voluto farlo con i fatti,
passando da un'idea ad una realtà.
E così è nato il MOAS.
Nel 2013, il Mare Nostrum
non era ancora iniziato.
Iniziò dopo la tragedia del 3 ottobre.
Quindi, molte ONG e operazioni
umanitarie lavoravano a terra.
Non ce n'era nessuna che lavorava in mare.
In mare, proprio lì dove tutte queste
persone stavano morendo.
Ma per andare in mare
avevamo bisogno di una nave.
Con mio marito, abbiamo cercato una nave.
La Phoenix, l'abbiamo trovata
a Norfolk Virginia.
La Phoenix è un vascello di 40 metri.
L'abbiamo riadattato
per il soccorso in mare,
l'abbiamo equipaggiato con un helipad,
con giubbotti di salvataggio "liferaft",
dottori, paramedici, coperte, vestiti,
per ridare umanità a queste persone
che quando prendevamo in mare
erano trattate peggio delle bestie.
Così, abbiamo deciso di continuare.
E quando abbiamo deciso di investire
nella tecnologia usando i droni,
gli altri ci credevano dei folli.
Dei "folli" perché volevamo andare
ad aiutare in mare delle persone,
come noi.
Soltanto che queste persone
hanno una pelle diversa.
Noi l'abbiamo fatto.
Siamo usciti da queste bolle di sapone
che sono belle ma non sono nulla.
Così, nel 2014, abbiamo
finanziato la nostra missione
e da agosto ad ottobre
abbiamo salvato 3.000 persone.
(Applausi)
Poi abbiamo lanciato il "crowdfunding",
la raccolta fondi per il 2015,
perché non ce la facevamo più,
non avevamo più i fondi per continuare.
Il 2 maggio siamo ripartiti
e a questi "folli"
si sono aggiunti MSF-Medici
senza frontiere,
la delegazione di Amsterdam
e "Salite in nave con noi" che oggi
si sta occupando del "post-rescue",
del post-soccorso.
Questa per noi è stata
una soddisfazione grandissima,
come ogni volta che portiamo
queste persone in mare.
Vorrei parlarvi di una storia che mi ha
colpito tantissimo e mi sta molto a cuore.
Mandate l'immagine di Honey
e la sua mamma per favore.
Questa è la storia di un bambino
che è salito in nave di notte.
La sua mamma ce lo ha portato in braccio
dicendo "help help!", "aiutami!".
Subito con il dottore l'abbiamo
portato in clinica.
Non capivamo se questo bambino
fosse morto perché non rispondeva.
Poi il dottore ha controllato
ed aveva la febbre altissima.
Così, dopo diverse ore, si è ripreso.
Io, come donna, come madre, non riuscivo
a togliere lo sguardo dalla mamma.
I suoi occhi erano disperati.
Una madre che poteva perdere
il proprio figlio
perché non c'era nemmeno una medicina,
un antibiotico, una tachipirina
che poteva salvargli la vita.
Una cosa di così semplice
che noi abbiamo
nel cassetto della cucina,
loro non l'avevano.
Poi Honey si è ripreso e adesso lo vedete
mentre gioca con la sua mamma
e i suoi amichetti sulla nave, gli abbiamo
dato dei vestitini, un giocattolo...
Lui è un bimbo di 3 anni, che colpa ha
se in Eritrea c'è la guerra,
se in Siria non si può più stare.
Che colpa ne ha?
Adesso, noi siamo rientrati.
Io ho fatto parte di diverse missioni
e c'è una bambina
che mi ha veramente emozionato.
È lei, è scesa qualche settimana fa,
l'abbiamo sbarcata ad Augusta.
E lei mi ha dato la forza
di scrivere questi passi
che vorrei condividere con voi
per concludere questa sera.
Si chiama "Milioni":
"Milioni. Milioni di occhi.
Milioni di mani. Milioni di bimbi.
Milioni di madri e milioni di padri
che prezzo non hanno,
ma un prezzo han pagato
e di loro tutto è stato violato.
Arrivare in Europa o morire? Lo sanno.
Non c'è alternativa. Non c'è umanità.
La casa mia brucia. La finestra è di là.
Questa è la mia unica possibilità.
Soffrire provando o morire restando?
Pregando, sperando che arrivi in Europa:
la terra di pace che guerra non ha.
Milioni han pagato, milioni.
Milioni di corpi raccolti nel mare.
Milioni di storie, milioni di vite,
salvate e sommerse.
L'amore che vince, il credo che spinge
ad andare per mare a cercare la gente
che fugge da dove più pace non v'è.
Ciao!
(Applausi)